I heard a rumor I don't know if it's
true but of course everyone is obsessed
with Michael Jordan and that documentary
the last dance which people yeah yeah
fantastic and whole new appreciation as
if we needed to be reminded but we did
about just how intense Michael Jordan
but in his career I'm told that you at a
celebrity event to raise money a charity
event who were the celebrity coach and
you were the first coach then that
coached Michael Jordan and Magic Johnson
when they were on the same team they
hadn't never played together this was
before the Olympics right you know it's
funny you get to a certain age and you
have your memories and you remember
something and you go that can't be true
that really didn't I'm imagining that so
Magic Johnson is this week's current
guest on the podcast and I asked him I
said remember when I coached your
celebrity charity game in Los Angeles in
the 80s and you and and Michael played
together that wasn't the first time you
guys ever set foot of the court together
was it he said yes it absolutely was so
that is a 100% true story you were that
you were the celebrity coach in that
situation I don't know what I would do I
would either do it absolutely nothing or
I would get in their faces a lot yes me
annoying would it be better yeah yeah
play basketball better I did I did get
to the point where like I mean I'm one
of the celebrities and I've been doing
nothing I mean what are you gonna do
I've been sitting on the bench for the
whole game and I figured I better do
there's like two minutes left in the
game and I figured I better do something
is I called a 20-second timeout by the
way I was dressed like Pat Riley as one
does the Armani suit on I haven't her
slicked back yeah and I called a
20-second timeout when I got out there
they huddled around and they all looked
at me and I I think we had like chrome
alone was on the team Mark Jackson was
on the team I mean everybody and I had
nothing to say of course and I looked
over though at Michael and he was
and he looked at magic in a magics being
his magic self having a good time I
think the score was 240 at that point no
one played any defense michael was like
hey men you wouldn't win this and all of
a sudden you could see the light bulb go
off and magics Henry like oh Jesus
Christ he means it yeah then of course
it got really competitive but that's who
Michael was it was is all fun and games
and for money but Michael wanted to win
100% all the time I love it I love it
it's a you're supposed to be just joking
around it's for charity and even in that
moment which when you've seen the
documentary you could totally see that I
think I would have pulled him from the
game I think I should have I should have
that's what you should have done you
should have said Michael I'm making you
out you don't have what it takes and can
you imagine can you imagine what he
would have done oh I call time out for
the last shot and I make Michael pass
the ball
Michael so in this you just got it you
just got a hit you know Mike Shrek like
some celeb some celebrity who clearly
can't play you know so yes you have to
hit Balki from perfect strangers for the
final shot 100% I should have done it
that would have been great I was too
scared I was intimidated around those
guys they were there was a moment where
Karl Malone ran past magic and Michael
and I we were all sitting that Julie
what a bad coach I was because there was
an actual moment where both magic and
Michael Jordan were on the bench with
you which would mean you a terrible
coach I was but I remember it vividly
because Carl Malone ran past us and it
was like a freight train where that the
dust and the air troubles behind it and
debris and I just remember them both
looking each other because I think
Malone was a rookie yeah say would you
ever take it take a hard foul from that
man and they were like hell no no no